Hello and welcome to a Conner's Clinic members minute. This is Michelle Hamburger
and I am here with Dr. Conner's. Today we are going to talk about Black SAV and Black SAV blood root
and the ways that we use this in our clinic and how it can be beneficial for many of our patients when utilized in different ways.
So blood root is an herb and so many herbs are beneficial for our health in so many different ways.
The blood root has been one of those quote-unquote cancer killers that people have spoken about. It can be very beneficial.
You have to be very careful with it because it is a fairly caustic herb and it can cause a lot of irritation.
You have to be careful with how to use it. We use typically three forms in our office.
The one that you see here is a blood root sound that is made with some creams and some other herbs mixed in with it.
This is what you see that is used for topical cancers, topical skin lesions.
You do it to be very careful with it and make sure you use it under a doctor's control because it can draw out cancer
but it can be extremely painful. Usually you need payments to follow with it.
These Black SAV capsules, these don't tend to cause any symptoms taken correctly, seem to be easy to ingest.
Don't get broken down into the intestines and don't really cause any problems.
These are more if you want to get the blood root into your body.
Systemically, it can be good for colon cancer, liver cancer, other different cancers.
Again, make sure you have doctors supervision when utilizing it.
But this is ground the root itself that is ground.
We use this quite often as we mix it with different products that we've created.
Like mushroom products, we use blood root mushroom mix.
It can taste pretty bad. It's pretty strong tasting herb.
So that could be an issue and that's where you're using it.
If you're trying to get it systemically using it with a capsule, it should sometimes be a little bit better.
But just a straight ground herb can be very beneficial for a lot of different things and a lot of different uses as well.
When using either black salve or blood root, be a contraindicated or a bad idea.
Well, definitely with the black salve, if you have an open, wounded, open tuber, let's say a breast cancer that's coming out,
you'd have to be used great amount of caution because it will draw the cancer further out and it can cause an enormous amount of pain.
It is said that you don't want to use more than the size of a dime size,
but any skin lesion or any topical lesion.
So you just have to use a lot of caution.
You can buy this stuff out of the market, but you have to be really, really careful using it because it is very, very powerful.
As far as contraindication to the capsules, I don't really see any except if you have ulcer.
That would be a contraindication.
If you have a stomach ulcer or a doybill ulcer, then it could cause a lot of irritation.
And maybe worse than ulcer, you'd be careful with that.
That's why you want to be under doctor's supervision with that.
Same day with the powder.
If you're suggesting that morally, you've got to be careful with the amount that you use.
For instance, how much we use typically of this powder is in a pint of mushrooms.
We may be only using a tablespoon of the powder, so it's very low dose.
You certainly would not take this by itself.
You probably gang on it, first of all, it tastes horrible.
And secondly, it could be very irritated at the stomach, so you'd have to be careful with it.
Would anybody that has an open sore or wound due to the cancer have any benefit in doing the blackstab
or because of the nature of it, it would be so painful that they probably wouldn't get the benefit they'd like from it?
Would it say, yeah, it would be very painful.
You'd really have to have a lot of supervision with it.
You'd have to be careful with it because again, it does kill cancer directly.
That's the beauty of blackstab or black in the blood room.
It kills cancer directly, but it does so by drawing it out.
And that's going to cause a great amount of inflammation.
This is what it's doing.
It's creating this inflammatory site there that's dried in your tea cells to help kill those cancer cells.
Which is great, but the side effect is paid because you got all this inflammation at this site of your skin.
And it's going to be extremely painful and you're going to need some medical support.
When I was last doing research on blackstab, I had also been reading that they recommend there are certain parts of the body that you shouldn't be doing it.
You wouldn't put blackstab on your nose for the fact that you could actually eat away at part of the nose itself or on your lip.
You could end up the blackstab, could eat away a part of your lip and your body wouldn't be able to regenerate that part.
But you got to weigh that out too.
I mean, what's the other solution if you got cancer on your nose?
And they're going to surgically remove your skin and your cartilage there.
You're not going to have anything left either.
So when you do blackstab as a topical exam for kill cancer, you're going to leave a wound.
So it's not going to heal back perfectly.
Like you don't know that anything was there.
You are going to leave a wound.
What you have to weigh out is, do you want a wound from the cancer?
Be pulled out and drawn out from a natural herb?
Or do you want to surgically remove it, which could possibly spread the cancer all over?
And it's still going to leave a ginormous wound.
So don't think that just because it's a natural approach, it's going to just be miraculous and everything's going to go away.
If you have any side effects from it, a natural approach you can have.
Side effects from it, pain, wound, formation.
If it's in the cartilage of your nose, you can lose the cartilage of your nose.
It's not going to grow back.
You're going to be left with a scar either way.
So you do need to be informed before you just go buy something on the internet and then utilize it.
For instance, we don't sell black samples on our website just because of that cost of danger.
But we don't want somebody to use it. That's it on the floor.
So the most important thing is if you're going to be using it that you do talk with your health care practitioner
or with one of us at Conor's Clinic to be able to see if this would be the right thing for you.
Right, absolutely.
All right, well thank you very much.
Thank you.